lebanon's caretaker prime minister is
warning his country is days away from
what he calls a
social explosion hassan diab is
appealing for help to avoid
outright economic ruin the world has
offered a financial lifeline but once a
government formed first with a reform
plan to deal with corruption
diabetes says the global community must
step in
now
i plead today to all the kings
princesses presidents
leaders and ally and friendly nations
and i call on the united nations and all
international agencies in public opinion
to help save the lebanese people from
death and prevent the destruction of our
country
lebanon is at a short distance from a
social explosion
and the lebanese are facing the stark
fate on their own
zenith has more now from bay roots
the country is in crisis it has been in
crisis
for more than a year the state is near
nearly bankrupt
and it's just a daily struggle for every
lebanese we're outside
one of the gas stations here and you see
the long
lines people wait for hours just to fill
up one third
of their fuel tank there is a fuel
crisis
just as there is a lack of medicine
after people fill up their cars with gas
they go to pharmacies to start looking
for medicines which more often than not
they do not find
and then there's hyper inflation the
price of food
it has more than tripled in recent
months
yet the minimum wage remains the same
and the majority of the lebanese people
earn in
the local currency which is now worth
less than 50
dollars and the reason is anymore
we're dying they are destroying us we
are destroying us
we have money we cannot buy anything we
have money
really we have money but we cannot buy
anything that's not life
it's a hell there are those there are
those people who still earn a salary
but unemployment is on the rise it's now
35 percent
and research institutes say it is going
to increase uh to 40 percent
uh the this is a country which is
starving for dollars
for hard currency and the central bank's
mandatory reserves is drying out and the
central bank was giving importers
dollars in order to you know buy fuel
medicine at an affordable price to
subsidize these goods
and like i mentioned it's running out
fuel prices have increased by
by 50 by 50 so has
the price of bread so people are
struggling
those and you just heard that man there
those who have money and who are able
to buy something just can't because they
cannot find it in a country which
imports
almost everything that it needs
one of the gulf countries that's offered
to help is qatar they've sent
the foreign minister to beirut for more
talks
mohammed bin abdulrahman al-thani is
meeting president michel aoun
prime minister designate sar hariri as
well as the commander
of the lebanese army now during his last
visit back in february he said
assistance
was dependent on the formation of a new
lebanese government now the world bank
describes lebanon's economic crisis as
the worst
anywhere for 150 years more than half
the country's population is now living
in poverty
lebanon's currency the pound has lost
about 90
of its value since the end of 2019
tens of thousands of people have lost
their jobs pushing the unemployment rate
to
40 and food prices
have soared a liter of milk for example
uh just under two dollars in 2019 that
now costs
6.60 while cooking oil is up from 1.30
to more than 20 dollars
let's get more now from sami nader he's
the
director of the levant institute for
strategic affairs which has a focus
on economics and public policy he joins
us by skype
from bay routes and we've been hearing
how lebanon
is in crisis for years now but it seems
different at the moment how close would
you say the comp
the country is to full collapse
it's a free-fall collapse you know the
country is like
falling from an airplane uh
without any
any safety net any uh parachute to
to mitigate its shock and we're not
seeing
the bottom yet it's not like the country
hit the bottom but uh it's a free fall
with no uh site when it will reach
the the the the full breakout
uh the fact is that the the currency has
lost 90 percent
of its value meaning the purchasing
power
have dwindled to the maximum the
average salary is less than
45 dollars meaning less than two dollars
a day
if you take for instance the array
salary of a soldier
in charge of maintaining the security uh
this his uh the salary today
is less than two dollars which does not
cover the cost
of him going to his military banks
so this is to say what is at stake it's
not
only the economic collapse the
economic situation but the very
existence
of the country and the sustainability of
the state
as a guarantor this is what
is at stake and this can have a huge
impact on the geopolitics of the region
in a region
that is very unstable
this can have i mean large consequences
on the neighborhood on europe because
this country is
at the southern border of europe all the
lebanese
including the 2 million syrians 6
million potential refugees
we're talking here so before we look at
the before we look at the
uh the consequences of this let's just
talk figures i mean how much cash does
the lebanese government have on hand
is its cash all in the lebanese pound
which is worthless
does it have foreign currency how is it
paying its bills
i mean now the country has an empty
coffers
i mean they are drawing what's remaining
of private money i mean they are
they are using what's remaining of
uh the reserves on the central bank in
other terms
what's remaining of the deposits of
the citizen let's keep in mind
that even the central bank has huge
losses
more than 56 billions in terms of
losses this is according to the
government plan
last year and the fact
now that the central bank is
the the founder of the government
even though is uh he has losses
so are we talking about these notes are
we are we talking about days now before
essentially the government can't pay any
of its bills i mean it seems like it's
coming down to the wire we've got the
lebanese army offering tourist joy rides
in order to raise funds for salaries and
equipment repairs if army salary
at one point did army's salaries stop
getting paid because this isn't just
humiliating this is a national security
issue
if the army is going to stop getting
paid and that could be within a matter
of days
one can assume i mean when's the army is
the army going to turn on the the
government i mean
just give us a sense of what is going to
happen
and when the army the army the soldiers
i mean are not uh we are witnessing a
phenomenon which has
many civil servants a civil servant
today are not going every single day to
their
work because they
they can't afford it they can't afford
it simply and
we we're using we're seeing this
phenomenon even
in the army so the army is
very cautious about the fact this is why
the commander-in-chief has raised the
alarms
two months ago this is why the
international community
is up to now trying to support the army
convening in europe in paris trying to
support the army's food unit
but this is not enough this may help on
the very very short run
but this is sustainable
and in my view if the liquidity is not
injected in the system in a very
short term this could lead to the total
freeze
of the lebanese state and all the
consequences we were talking
about and the only way to inject today
money as a program was imf because the
international community
is ready and this is the conundrum the
international community
is ready to help lebanon provided
lebanon
uh does the reform and up to now
the lebanese authorities the lebanese
political establishment is not capable
of forming a government
to trigger the reform process so so
given the state of the country that it's
in
given the the the challenges that you've
laid out
the security issues at play what's
on earth are lebanese lebanon's leaders
doing they're in an international game
of chicken with lenders
and it's striking that the prima the
caretaker prime minister is saying we
need your money but we
can't we're going to impose conditions
on taking it what are they playing at
i mean this is i mean this is the
the saree i mean this is what the
surreal
landscape we're seeing this is
totally i mean this is totally crazy
excuse me
because the political establishment is
seeing a country sinking risking king
seeing a country that that is
disappearing
it is a total meltdown and up to now
it's not capable to breach their
differences
and to form a government in fact in my
view
uh the what's behind this
this apparent conflict between the
political faction
is the fact that forming a government
is still a bargaining ship in the hand
of iran
and it wants to use it because let's
face it
iran got the upper hand hezbollah is
controlling the country
he has enough leverage to put pressure
on hariri and round
to form government he showed that he's
capable of doing so
when he they formed the government of
tam salam
after more than one year of
constitutional
vote but today it's different because
it's in
a total economic collapse and up to now
in vienna there is no sign of a
breakthrough
with iran and iran maybe has many other
priorities than forming a government in
lebanon and it's the the
the same situation or the same case uh
with
the american it's true that the
uh the international community want
uh this country to be saved
however let's face it it's not a
priority
neither on the american side nor on the
iranian side
okay sammy nader we'll have to leave it
there great to get your thoughts so
thank you so much for joining us
from beirut